alright welcome everybody huh can you
hear me okay no okay let's try the mic
maybe I got to turn it on no it's on
hello testing 01 testing testing can
anybody hear me now raise your hand if
you can hear me how did you okay well
well you know i'm not sure if i could
shout but let's hope the mag could pick
it up is it okay oh the humming okay all
right well let's fix that before before
we go okay so somebody's working on the
hum eight yeah I got a beautiful I I got
a beautiful blue glow on that mine
through there too I don't write so on
meanwhile oh I better not even try to
talk if you can't hit me right
now is it better hello no not better
okay well I'll fix it up well are
waiting to figure that out let me just
say are there anybody any Stanford who
might be interested on a on a project
without funding this summer that might
take a week math problem have any okay
well this is nippy in the what I'm
not just suited up you'll be happy to do
it you're not a student yeah okay all
right I'll maybe talk about it a little
bit what water it is that is the audio
working now I we want to help us tonight
ah here we go I see plan B
ok so it might be louder first so he
will bring it out welcome to the park
with you can see from the title will
graph and I I guess the main reasons i'm
i'm doing here to celebrate that I
finding that I fine hello welcome to
computer musings with ender and the
engine to Stanford University the the
center of audio technology and the
reason that I wanted to give this talk
today is is is partly you know selfish i
like to celebrate the fact that i
finally know what the first 46 pages of
volume four of the art of computer
programming are going to look like
please don't it's a project that i
started in 1962 and actually i still
have a i still have another two inches
on page 46 that i might think of
something to put on there but that but
but it even if it's it was left blank
it'll be okay anyway it's it's uh let's
put it up on the screen you can download
it very easily if you go to my if you go
to my homepage and then go to the news
page at the top of the news page it
tells you how to get free Prescott Jason
can you put this on can you focus on
this here we go right so at the top of
the news page it'll tell you how to get
the pre fascicle 0 a and there is also 0
B 0 c and 1a that are available now
these are I know we got a lot of Google
people here in the first couple of rows
and you can also i don't know that the
it used to be that you could get to my
homepage just by typing down but that's
not true anymore so so if you guys can
do anything about that I appreciate it
but but i but i notice that google
already has stand has scanned the text
of this and your sentences inside of
this appearing already in the search was
so that's pretty impressive and so I
just put this online couple weeks ago
now I guess I might as well give a
little look ahead already I'm vol.4
there are these paperback things that
called fascicles two three and four
which are approximately you know things
that come in the middle of volume 4 and
it was going to be I don't know probably
dozens of these all together because vol
4 is going to be our God willing is
going to be volume for a B and C and I'm
not sure off how much further but quick
though I don't think there'll be a Z so
it but anyway it god it's there's a lot
of stuff to say in there but I couldn't
I couldn't really like the beginning
first you know to write if you're a
computer programmer you you write the
initialization less it's a little bit
hard to say what what you need the boots
that the whole thing so first I got
these done and these are you know
available and translated already into
several languages and and and now
in the fall or we're going to publish 0
's equal zero and and what but what's
available online is the pre festival
which is which is called with otherwise
known as data test and and this is this
is your chance to look at this material
before too many other people have seen
it because I pay good money for anybody
who finds errors in the in text up
unless somebody else Tom here first and
for example while I was preparing for
today I I notice an error on page 30 so
you don't you know you could have
yesterday you could have found it and
and told me about it and made two
dollars into sixth sense that's but
today I already I already know that one
and it I don't like to be the one who
catches these there's no I mean I like
to hope that somebody else is actually
reading the stuff now the only way the
pre fascicles 0 a B and C are going to
are going to go together into fascicle 0
and that should come out october
november or something like that now I've
also got pre-festival 1a on the web and
that is even cooler than cool grass I
have to say it's all about it's called
bitwise tricks and techniques and it and
it collects the folklore that I've
learned over the years about how to make
use of of the instructions that most
computers have but but people think are
only good for one or two one or two
think and and right now I'm having a
having a ball writing pre-festival 1b
which I I think i should get done and
cutting into three months which is about
representing boolean functions and and
it's a
I don't know yesterday and vanilla what
might be a new and we really interesting
data structure and I and I'm having a
lot of fun writing writing that / so
then the plan is that that 1a and 1b
will be put together into festival one
early next year so then we'll have 0 1 2
3 and 4 but that's that'll be I don't
know 500 pages or so but it's still not
enough to put out into a hardback so
then I'm going to get a couple I'm going
to I'm going to finish up a couple other
book projects and then and then come
back and do best of five maybe six and
then we'll come up with a real hard
hardcover it would be a while but if
your shirt I'm wearing it says so art of
computer programming volumes for that my
wife made this shirt for me as a jokes
on me send me some well maybe 20 years
ago and I wear it every time I can
report a little bit of progress on the
front okay now so if you were okay so
this is an induction to combinatorial
searching which is the main topic of
what Valley for it and and one of the
most important things in combinatorial
algorithms is other than that work on
graphs because graphs are everywhere in
in applications and and it's the most
how many ways the most versatile of all
the comments are structured so so
naturally I also this is largely an
introduction to do graphs and if you
were writing a book that was
introduction to graphs well I'll try to
think what you would what you do you
have to circa course give a whole bunch
of definitions and and explain the basic
things about that's up and one of the
main things that you probably do is is
try to have a lot of cool examples and
and then so so so in these in these 46
pages plus answers to the exercises
60 days in any pages I I've gone
introduction to graph theory and that
also i think is has a lot of interesting
examples and a few algorithms that don't
go into graph algorithms per se but but
into into specific topics on graphs like
you know how to how to find a maximum
matching or something like this but but
instead graphs that that I mean
algorithms that are sort of close to the
definitions in some sense that helped to
reinforce the whole whole idea of what
the pressure now um let me show you then
a few of the illustrations in here and
that before i get into the main thing I
wanted to discuss today which is one of
these one of these algorithms that I
think that I that I got excited about as
I was writing okay well I'd actually
don't get to grab some I mean I
start talking about playing cards and
other other kind of comic are things for
a while and but I do i do finally get to
grasp on on page 13 graph theory the
basics and and on page 14 you can see
here is here here some pictures so Jason
can we get a close-up of this of where
I'm pointing here
ah hello Jason yeah good so so I'm going
to be doing this a lot i'm going to be
pointing to the book a lot you don't
want to watch me watch the book here are
examples of some of the most important
graphs of small size so so so you know
for example to Grandpa ten vertices the
Petersons graph has to be has to be the
winner of the most interesting graph of
this kind has been used over the years
to to service counter examples for
almost every conjecture that somebody
had that that is really true about
graphs are usually it starts out the
smallest counter example is the
Petersons graph man and even Peterson
when he first published it he was giving
a counterexample to somebody else of
conjecture and there's a whole book that
does a whole book written about the
Peterson great the most important graph
on eight vertices is probably the three
cube shown here you know graphs can be
drawn in many different ways all of
these graphs down here are also the same
as the three exactly the same graph but
but different ways presented show you
different things about now the one up
here in the corner a schwa Telegraph is
my my vote for the most interesting
graph on 12 vertices and out and we can
talk a little bit more about that later
now now logical at all was it was a
professor here at Stanford during the
70's and one of the one of the best in
graph theory was gone on to do many
other kinds of mathematics as well and
is now at Concordia University in
Montreal which is his favorite City he
always said it was in love with Montreal
even when he was at Stanford so we had
we were lucky to get him here for for
almost ten years now but if you go to
his home page you find that he has a
picture of this graph on 12 vertices
which he published in the 70s nearly 70
s and the reason was
well it's the smallest graph that has
several properties that that i can
describe a minute his home page he still
draws the graph this way but when i
wrote to when i wrote to him asking more
of the story of the graph he said you
know his friend Adrian boundary has just
found it a new way to draw this graph
that shows what that shows more of its
symmetries and so this is the way Adrian
Bondi draws Patrick strap and I I think
studied a while you'll see that it
actually is cool now logix home page
also has a whole bunch of other stuff
the assessee to rebut it so sometimes if
you want to see some some more stuff but
ok let's rock that done what is that
what is it its original claim to fame oh
and I'll get all just rated not not
prove it just official just so you get
the idea of him maybe I better look it
up but in the index if I'm going to find
it there is an index at the back you get
it you get two dollar fifty six cents
for every error in the index if
something isn't in the index should be
no I cave would got to get this got to
get this book right so his graph yeah is
discussed on page 12 14 39 44 and 62 so
let's look on page 39 it says somewhere
what tells graph how many symmetries
that spot Telegraph down
so you can say how many you know how
many ways are there to the vertices and
so that the the edges stay the same so
you remember the vertices so that every
vertex V goes instead to F of E and then
you know definitely is adjacent to f of
you if and only if you and he were
adjacent to each other in original graph
how many symmetries does it have okay so
that's an exercise there but that's on
page that was on page 39 what about page
44 here's where we get to the reason
that he really that he really discussed
it and and that is asked about coloring
it so the middle number of colors that
you need to cut to color this graph and
also it also turns out to be a okay so
get the I'll get the picture of the
graph on the screen again and you have
to convince yourself that you that you
can't color that with three colors and
then as we look at the answer to
exercise room on the floor by the way
it's allowed to look at the answers but
you're supposed to think about the
exercise and so there's there's a proof
one answered answer 124 why you need
four colors court and and then but this
isn't official what's called the girth
of a graph now the girth of a graph is
the length of the smallest cycle so you
see there's no three cycles in this
traffic no triangles but
there's a cycle of length their glass of
cycling for you can go around like make
that a square so this is a this is a
graph that happens to need need for
colors to color it and it and it has
girth floor and also every vertex has
exactly four neighbors so it's a regular
graph also of degree 4 and it wasn't
easy to find a graph that was that was
regular beautiful it needed four colors
and also had birth for now there's a
famous unsolved problem in in graph
theory some are more famous than others
but this one is one is one of the better
one of the one of the winners I got to
make sure I don't get my and that is it
is called room bombs conjecture and and
and inbound fine found one that had
growth five now a man in Germany named
Brinkman who I contacted by email he
showed that there's a graphic 21
vertices and and it has you know for
regular or color bow and the smallest
cycle is linked five and nobody knows if
there's one in his girth six or seven or
something although Greenbaum conjectured
that you could do this for all you know
for all larger larger births and
computer search has been done up to up
to thirty four vertices to find one of
more than five but there aren't any so
you've got to have at least thirty five
vertices that you're going to win that
so that's a schwa tells crack
what the graph that that I I think it's
most fun of all actually in the whole
business is the graph of based on words
of English so it's not so mathematical
as this is not regular it's not it's not
about any of this other stuff but
instead it's based on what i consider
all the 5-letter words of the english
language now for 20 years I went and
made my personal collection of a
five-letter words just because of just
because the word is in the dictionary
doesn't mean to me that's a word it's no
fun if you're playing Scrabble against
somebody who just has a bigger
dictionary than you and your own custom
comes up with these things to me it's
you know if I'm going to use it an
example it should be a word that I
believe is a word that someone like
season and so you know I I spent several
hours interviewing my daughter asking
her how many five it or if she knew I
also made mystics like to figure out you
know which ways are more common in
others and for years and years I went on
saying I wonder if this is in my list
and I and I checked it against course of
various dictionaries to get going and
there was a famous dictionary called the
gyro dictionary that I that we had on
one of the first ones in in in early
days of computers and anyway five-letter
words turn out to be more interesting
than all other words and six other words
as but I don't have time according to
all what he tells about that but anyway
I came up with with it with what I
considered a complete set and then it
was time to freeze the set and say now
from now on I'm never going to change
this anymore i'm going to start i'm
going to say these are the words as they
existed in ennis in a certain data set
which that which is no fixed for all
time and it's not going to you know it's
been end up so that i don't have to
worry about I came to update my book or
anything else with never change now
these words are all are all part of a
something called the Stanford
graph-based I gave a lecture when using
lecture
this so maybe 10 12 years ago and this
book has is still in print but its sales
are flat so if anybody you know wants to
suggest something to your parents you
know Esther would be a great present two
to have the you know I mean it's a it's
it's a fairly fun to read this book
contains a three dozen short short
algorithms that worked on graphs are
presented as examples of rigid programs
and also has brought immense pictures
etc and it includes at the end of the
most common 3005 letter words of English
asthma pendant so you can see them you
can see them here a real not here okay
so a back is it is number 2476 of eight
2877 okay about or above 49 so each one
has a ranking one of three thousand
actually the total number of five other
words of English according to me is 57
57 but I don't give all of them here
because I didn't expurgate the I mean
you know some five of the words are
pearls of four-letter words and so you
might it might embarrass my t
embarrassing to have them on television
so so but the first three most common
3,000 are pretty safe so so they're in
not that if you if you think of it
either word that you know that that you
that you might think it's a little bit
risque you can still look it up in the
database it now now why does this have
to do with graphs include grass well
it's because there's a there the Lewis
Carroll invented again in the at the end
of 1877 based on on changing one word
into another by changing what letter at
a time people know this but it's often
called word ladders or latter grams or
something like it and so for example
here's one of his example he changed
tears into smiles and tears Sears stars
their tails
ah ok so here we have a graph 5757
vertices to two of them are adjacent if
if if you only need to change one letter
to in the same position and so this
graph has lots of had lots of neat
properties and so almost every algorithm
that I that I'm going to do on graphs
throughout the volume or I'm going to
I'm going to have various ways to tie
this in with the graph of all
five-letter words and and try the
algorithm out on that graph and
constancy what can happen for example
right now I'm just writing festival I'm
just writing about that about BDDs late
especially billion functions and and I
decided to take these 5757 words and
consider him to be a function of 25
boolean variables because you can encode
each letter as a 5 in 5 bits we have 25
bits of n you see it's this pattern of
fiber toward or not and and I just you
know I just found out that it was only
about 6,500 nose in the in the ordered
or a decision diagram for this day of
stuff anyway so so I can find lots and
lots of examples of how to use these
words in graphs in and also another way
now the graph hello yeah so that that's
a very good question when you ask a
question there's a microphone in front
of you mean you're supposed to press the
red button it's the set fully connected
which is to say is it fully connected
can you get from any words to any other
yes in fact no I get here I ok so I so
the demonstration program you can
download it from my website and and you
can run it then and it will and it will
give you the shortest thing here so for
example up here's an example you say you
asked for four words and you try to
convert that into a ground
right so okay words wolves goals goals
grass there you go ask another starting
word flour to bread okay chaos to order
ok found two euros can't do it ok out
now it it turns out that there's two
reasons why this true you can't change
anything into euros there is no there's
no word adjacent to euros that it's you
know it's an isolated vertec and the
second reason is that tom is is is isn't
it it is a member of this small it would
rather large component but you can't
break out of it you can get powned hound
ground-bound sound sound ruled world you
can get to court found and so but you
this is it okay so it's not connected
but there's a giant component that so
the giant component has 40 493 words in
it from any of these you can get to any
of the other and then and I discussing
here quick usually like if you can get
two steps away from from your starting
word and two steps away from the
backward then your chances are something
like ninety six percent that that you're
in the giant component but pound is one
of the exceptions so how many sets are
there so so by the way the question how
many disjoint sets are there yeah that's
all answered in this book and for
example there's also there are some
components of size to that you know just
two words and some of them are kind of
cute like droid and druid you know alpha
Aloha so of it but then you can't break
out of those but but anyway lots of fun
with this and and not only for shortest
path algorithm but it makes a great demo
of different kinds of shortest path
algorithm to convert one to another but
but here for example there's a people
work on grass they have something called
a Steiner tree problem we try to find
the the shortest way to connect several
verses and so here I took blood sweat
and tears of no blood sweat and tears
and then you can only did these
connections this is the shortest way to
connect those three mostly work on the
cover of the on the cover of this I I
can hench marks you know with a with a
Steiner treatment okay so so so you can
you can work on lots of multiple or the
revolution on a fairly good-sized graph
that people can can Intuit what it means
and you can go straight to graph so I
think that's a lot of fun um now another
interesting one that I have here is the
draft is based on the United States
let's see that's on page 15 what
happened here i see i switched the page
okay so these are the what used to be
called the continental United States
know that nigga's United States and I
also added the District of Columbia so
you this is Delaware this just DC here
and so this is an example of course of a
planar graph and and it has 107 edges I
know that because I had to draw this
time thing and I had to lay it out on
the page and and when I had to make the
air all the illustrations in my book art
are generated by meta post and it's a
lot of fun to use that program but I
also could also have to you know add a
line in the code so as I was doing this
putting in all these all these 107 edges
between states so it was really a
wonderful nostalgic trip for me because
I could remember a different times in my
life when I when I drove between these
two states you know California Oregon oh
yeah
you know California Nevada Oregon Nevada
Oregon to Washington Washington Idaho
you know what's the way I told Montana
you know I went Wisconsin to Michigan
Michigan Ohio all these all these things
almost all of these I could remember at
some point in my life driving is so so
anyway I have to consider this a Krueger
also i got an illustration of on this
graph of the so-called accident
independent set algorithm etsy s that
comes in here oh yeah so it is
independence that as a graph is where
you choose vertices but no to know to
our next to each other and so here is a
maximal independence that means that i
can't add anymore and I can't add
California here because it's already
it's next to this guy down here which is
which must be Arizona so so I can't you
know what's okay so everything that I
haven't I haven't colored in is next to
one of the ones I've caught in so it's a
maximal independent set as 12 vertices
solely the ones that aren't that aren't
colored in that's called a vertex cover
and it's a minimum vertex cover with 49
minus 12 vs 0 so but but actually to get
a minimum vertex cover and a maximum
independence that you can actually find
19 states that have no no that a
mutually you can't drive from 12 yeah
and so lots of bug of graph algorithms
course can be can be demonstrated on me
on expert on these graphs and some of
the graphs have mathematical structure
like wat I'll strap but some of them
have an organic real-world structure
like 50 words or or the graph the United
States there's also oriented or directed
graphs and I and here I haven't really
found much much to do with algorithms
but I want
to prevent it because because this is
that this is a graph that appears in
Agatha Christie's novel Murder on the
Orient Express and and this this graph
was actually given by my air-cooled poor
role as he's trying to solve a mystery
and it the different vertices here are
the characters in the novel and and you
have an arrow if one has a alibi for the
other and so he's summarizing the status
of the other mystery and this is the
graph that he described in that I'm
still looking for you no reason to use
this in the algorithm but I had to put
it in the book anyway because they
thought it was cool now the Stanford
graph-based has he has not only
algorithms but graphs in it that are
that are intended for use in experiments
and I work with a lot of Stanford
students to prepare this some 20 years
ago and not only the 5-letter words but
several others i'm going to show you in
the next few minutes are are in there
and it's also there's a whole set of
software tools that go with this so that
you can easily be sure that you're
getting exactly the the graphs there's
the carefully some checks so that no
mistakes have been made of and that you
can then lots of ways to combine these
graphs to make many other bears from the
ones that are the ones that are given
the that there are lots of a graft the
libraries and sync programs available
but they all seem to be proprietary in
plus money this is free download it and
it's all and I'm going to base zillions
of examples on these on these graphs so
I so I went to a lot of trouble to make
this whole be easily available now let
me show you then just a few of these
first of all there's a graph-based
roget's thesaurus the original was Jay's
destroys from the 19th century bike by
peer of my crochet and his son and and
type of students helped me to key in all
this data so this has a 1022 vertices
and then there's a desert this is a
directed graph so there's a art from one
there's the concepts that that are into
the sorcerer is what is it there's an
art from water to moisture and arts and
discovering the truth you know an arc
from vulgarity to ugliness and so on all
of these are our examples so when
there's a cross-reference under one
topic of one general topic to another
you know when you look up water and says
he also moister than that then that
gives you a directed graph with some
interesting structure then they're
tender grass based on literature of
several several of several novels and
other books like The Iliad not always it
to odyssey one of those two it's one of
Homer's stuff do you think anyway this
is Jean Valjean this is the this is lame
is Rolla a graph that where the vertices
of the characters of the novel and the
edges are characters who encounter each
other somewhere and then there's also a
bipartite graph which has one vertex for
every character in one vertex for every
chapter of the book and the and then we
forget certain character appeared in
that chapter then you get an edge in the
graph as an example the bipartite graph
that would that you've been used for
testing algorithms on bipartite now I've
got to Mona Lisa in there I've got a
digitized version of Mona Lisa that you
can use to to get a cool grass out of
for example if you by the way this
close-up detail you're supposed to look
at it and far away I guess you're far
enough away but then you can you can say
how many levels are Brady one and you
can use that to define regions that are
connected
requires connected and then if those
regions are the vertices of the graph
and it's a planar graph and you can see
which regions are next to other region
there's that there's a graph based on
the cities in the United States and
Canada which has all the mileage how
exactly how long it takes to drive from
one city to another here's one night
that that's that's mathematical in
nature of the Ramanujan graft this is a
family of graph that's great that's uh
some of the best-known expander grass
that an expander graphs have a huge
number of application and so you can use
this demographic to experiment with the
ramaj on graphs which were invented by
Stanford professors well Phillips and
David sonic gonna and boo boskie and
they they actually had me hadn't
actually seen many of their graph until
I had this to software work in the show
of they prove the mathematical so make
graviton games here it shows all the all
the night moves that you can make in a
chess board at six by nine or any side
of the chest for lots of different ways
to get a graph based on them on on the
games that come before and
let's see there's also a part in his in
estar about five years ago or so in your
sought in this other time I gave a
lecture called tora tora tora about
Torres's and and and it was when i was
first thinking about some of these
graphs that i was going to use as an
examples and you see here's that of
course the lot of it times we want to we
think of a graph algorithm we want to
try it out on on on cases that we can
easily understand like a grid or a
cylinder and or a torus where the which
is like a good but wrapping around and
in that lecture that i gave about
torres's some musical type of what
passes as it does there are now in the
contents of that lecture are now
encapsulated on page 45 of where i work
where instead of having just a tourist
which is like a three by ford taurus
here which you can imagine that these 12
cells are replicated over and over again
in the plane and and it's the same as
these 12 vertices replicated all over
the two or the plaintiff turned out to
be the same draft that you can awesome
many more cases that don't fit into a
square like this as 13 vertices and tile
the plane other way and in that lecture
that i gave unfortunately the videotape
of that lecture by the way i loaned it
to somebody and they any i forgot who it
wasn't and we've never gone it back so
we can't put online now but maybe it's
just as well because I at the end I had
some problems I couldn't solve and and
now the answer is in exercise 138 so so
as I was reading this up it turned out
the ways it would actually a fairly
simple solution to up to the problem
that I was trying to solve that date
okay
quickly show you is also the graph on
page 44 which is which is cool any penny
what any of you are musicians because
this has 24 vertices one for every major
and minor king and then the easy
modulation from one key to another
lakeland see majored a minor what the C
major F major so on these are the this
this is a graph that that it's called a
musical graph this is dis grapple isn't
actually I found on me iphone an
abstract to three years ago lectured
given in England by Besser Robin Wilson
and so I will commit his the title this
lecture was beautiful graphs and so I
said well that's a great that's a great
title for electric can I can you send me
the paper that's based on these he
didn't have a paper but he sent me the
slides and this was the first slide in
his lecture on beautiful graph stuff and
and he used this as an example in his in
his web introduction to graph theory
book written for undergrads at the Open
University in England now I started it
for a while I said yeah this is really a
beautiful graph but but what can i but
is there any difficult problem to solve
about this graph that I could that I
could use as an exercise or his or
closed everything about this graphs are
easy to answer and and after a couple of
hours I couldn't think of an exercise
that would give me a good excuse to use
this death in the book and then I
realized oh no that's the answer this
graph is a graph in which all of the
questions are easy and so it makes a
great review question about all the
concepts in the intersection so what is
the order of this graph the size the
girth the diameter the independence
number the chromatic number
you know and so on and it turns out that
you know it it's a way to say oh I know
all these definitions and by the way
it's not too hard to solve any of these
parts of the club the exercise but there
is an unsolved problem about this graph
and that is the if is there a way the
draw this graph in the plane with with
fewer than 14 or whatever it is called
cousins and and that's the that I don't
know how so but ok so so I've shown you
a whole bunch of clue grass but now on
lick now let me show you that an
algorithm that I that which you can
generate graphs easily on while you have
while you're sitting in a meeting with
nothing else to do and and and it and
it's a and and it when I was writing
this it I happen to notice that there
was a very simple algorithm let's see
where is on page 29 here very simple
algorithm that I'm going to go up I'm
going to tell you about a four step
algorithm that that as one of the to me
was was a good solution as to what kind
of an algorithm will address can you put
into it into the first few pages where
you're introducing graph theory because
its algorithm that this talks about the
basic thing about the most basic thing
about death which is which is the
degrees of the vertices so let me give
me this is one of the first problems non
trivial problems to have been solved
about graphs inland in the 1950s but you
know what you know what the degree of a
vertex is its number of neighbors it had
and so available if we have a graph like
the like we can we can list all the
degrees of the vertices I told your
spotters graph every vertex that degree
for so okay that's 44 4 4 4 12 times but
but but there are some
some sequences of vertices that that are
impossible for example a fiber graphics
suppose the vertices are just 1 2 up to
n now you know these these are the
vertices people often almost always in
the book they'll call it v1 v2 up to VN
but they're just writing a whole bunch
of ease they all need to give this point
i call it so these are the vertices so
now okay so but but now they have they
have degrees and a d1 d2 up to DN and we
can choose the numbering in such a way
that the degrees keep getting smaller
okay now the one obvious thing has to be
cured if there's going to be a graph
that d1 can't be what's the largest
value of d one can have how many
neighbors can vertex one out n minus 1
that that's that you know so so so first
of all what one condition is that d1 has
to be less than or equal to n minus 1
has less than n the second condition is
that that the sum of all the degrees has
to be even does anybody know why that is
true it's because every edge contributes
to the degree of his two endpoints and
so we're coming so this is twice the
number of edges so okay now but that's
not enough because you can have a degree
sequence like 33 11 it's the easier it
gets the smallest stuff well there are
some there are some using zeros that are
writing leaf let's play this part of
this plugin is for let's try to find a
graph with degrees 33 11 so vertex one
has to be connected to three guys so
that's got to be connected to two three
and four
oh by the way I draw my graphs in the
book here with open vertices that's I
think that's cooler it's used by in the
in the book by by by bonding and Murdy
agent bonding nerdy I a lot of books
used to use solid ones but they but I
realize that that their method is
actually a wink and so now Burton so to
now has to has to be connected to three
guys as well okay fine so to us be
connected to everybody but now I'm
supposed to have one-on-one I'm not a
lot okay so all right so there's
something else going on here so we say
that a sequence of degrees is is
graphical if there is a if there exists
at least one graph that has that
sequence and i'm going to show you this
just nice this very beautiful simple
algorithm for which you can sit down as
I say in it if you happen to be in a
meeting there and have some graph paper
with you then you have to have graphed a
promoter work on grass but if in order
if you know instead of just doodling
might also run through this algorithm
because it because every different
sequence of degrees that seems to be a
little bit different when you play the
game and I'll suppose I'm taking now the
sequence 5 5 5 4 4 3 2 2 so I'm going to
I'm going to write this as just put
boxes here 5 5 5 4 4 3 2 2 and neither
slots which I'm going to put the
neighbors of vertices one two three four
when i'm 78 instead of trying to draw
the graph then you just you know i'm
going to put the edges in here so i'm
going this year the vertices that one
the neighbors of one neighbors with 2
and so on up the neighbors repeat okay
well how the algorithm I'm going to tell
you about never appeared in English
language before but it was it but but it
appeared in the Czech language in a
paper by Vaslav hovel in night in 1955
now this isn't Vaslav hovel who you
might have heard of as the president of
Czechoslovakia this is Vaslav hollow
mathematician who wrote this paper in
1955 and he wrote it in check but it was
but he used some mathematical formulas
in it so I'm pretty sure what he said in
the paper I can't be checked but but but
from the abstract of the paper and from
another the formulas in the sequencer
that occurred in the paper i'm pretty
sure you had this one and other people
have referred to this paper but they all
gave a much more complicated algorithm
and he himself to the original paper
soap so it's much simpler than then
other books explain this process and i
want to show you a little game that you
can play so ok now you start out and you
try to find the neighbors of eight first
and what you do is you you always try to
to to fill of slots on the right right
hand column first so so I'm going to Ike
i'm going to choose eight the two
neighbors of eight are both going to be
of either one two or three but i'm not
going to choose one because I because I
want to keep this I want to keep the
stag I'm always non decreasing order so
I'm going to I'm going to match 823 and
I'm going to match 822 you know that but
I yeah but a quick didn't go from top
down buddy from bottom up so that I
wouldn't wouldn't because otherwise I
we're going to do it luton glitchin I
don't want to itch it ok Wow do the same
thing with 77 is going to fit here and
so seven is matched to one and then then
who who else do I give 75 okay so six
seven goes and six is going to go here
here and here I so that's 4 cm to 5 is
going to go to one it's getting a little
e little more interesting here so 5 is
getting to one sorry and then and then
four and three right the four put a fits
we've got 240 that's perfect 2 and 13 is
going to go to you see we've got to fill
this guy in I don't want to send three
to itself but that's okay I just make it
so I threes here and then great 21 okay
so now we've got a graph with degrees
one two three four you know he's 5 5 5 4
4 3 2 2 and that sequence was graphical
if i start up with 33 11 it wouldn't
work but there oh ok well let's take
this let's take another one I got I was
going to ask for a suggestion from the
audience but I don't have much time when
he saw the time I don't want to go too
far over so let me do another another
one that I have can in advance that will
show you a little more what's going on
766 Arkansas Emma 76 643
now that's not cool 2211 debt let's see
that's not the one I wanted to show you
that let's just go to page page 43 go
first listening to do speak when ok um
ok 866 up here we go so one two three
four five six seven eight six six and
then six four one two four six okay
there we go so here's nine vertices and
I want to want to see if this sequence
is graphical ok so so the question is
who are it going to be the neighbors of
nine but if you can give 94 neighbors so
I want to use this column so I put a 9
here but now I can't use this column you
see because I can't make one neighbor
twice tonight so I gotta drop down to
this column here and I'm going to go
here next these two guys and so these
are three and two and then where is the
next I'm going to go eight right so
so so the algorithm is just a little bit
tricky chief justice but which means
that you know it's just enough to keep
your mind occupied during this communion
because because you choose the right
most column and you work bottom up but
then you have to but then you have to go
to the next group of of things you have
to go to the next notch and then then
whip them up at that machi young and so
on but let's keep on going aight has
three guys so that's pretty easy whoo no
no no eight comes over here here and
here doesn't it ok so that's how 13 into
the order in which i put these doesn't
matter of course it's just going to be
the neighboring here so seven is going
to go here here here and here so seven
gets you know to 16 five or six has now
got to find three neighbors and i can
put here here in here um so that's 15 is
going to go 15 is going to do so but I
better fill it in its 143 of is it going
to be graphical or yes no problem three
again we win all right now you might
want to see an example where we don't
win so so that's this one so what
happens when it when it fails and on ok
so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 i'll let you do this
to make sure so let you make one make
sure you understand what's going on here
nine is going to be placed we're up here
with one very good 83
seven just going to be here okay 68 in
1434 or here here and here ah it's okay
made it of 2133 no problem ok and to
here is where I guess I've got it
footage here I'm stuck because i've got
i reduced it to finding a graph you know
on two vertices where somebody has a
degree of two can't be done so so
hello hi is this what blue yeah that's
good okay so now the I I was going I
thought I'd have time to give a proof of
this because the proof is actually not
not difficult but instead I just refer
you to page 30 because because this it's
hard to fall proof unless I had us had a
attendance to really explain it slowly
but the the main idea is that if yep
certainly if the algorithm succeeds then
you've proved it graphical because
you've got a graph but if it doesn't you
want to show that the mission was
impossible and the reason is that that
the the strategy i'm using here which is
that this sort of you know the rightmost
bottom most strategy replacing
everything is the most conservative
thing if the ND the basic basic reason
is is an important property called major
ization of of sequences like like a
degree sequence and and it occurs in
many many comets or algorithms where you
say that 11 list of numbers major eyes
is another and it means that the sum of
the that the first guy is bigger okay so
let's say sequence a major eyes a
sequence would be beat that means that a
1 is greater than or equal to B 1 and a
1 plus a 2 is greater or equal to a2 + 8
a b1 plus b2 and similarly the sum of
the first Kas is greater than or equal
to some of the first case
beast that's called major ization and it
arises it arises a lot and I discuss it
actually in fascicle 3 here if I look in
the index under major ization I got a
nice picture I can show you page 126
page 126 know that an error in the index
oh no there's a main references page 58
80 okay so here's major ization for
example of all all the partitions of 12
all the ways to set two numbers thats
under 12 you can see some major eyes
other ones like 53 10 11 major eise's
522 1 11 and age your eyes is also 4 4
101 but it doesn't major Isaac eyes over
here so anyway make these are these
degree sequences are partitions of the
the total number of things that have the
same sum that and what what happens is
that if if one sequence major I you know
if if Quincy on 2dn major eyeses d 1
prime 3d n prime um and and the first
one that these are graphical then so is
the other one are the smaller ones so if
a graphical sequence mages major eyes
another one the other one is also
graphical and so what we've done is
we've sort of fine found the sequence so
that no matter who I who I match it up
with here if I match eight up and I
might have match it up with six and
three or with you know one two buckle
but I can match it up with with
you know any of any of the other two
guys but whichever whichever one I chose
its major it what's left after I've
deleted the ACE is going to be major
eyes by what I did and so I so I'm
making the you know I'm making the
safest the safest assignment short so I
can't be killing any graphical sequences
by this method and that's that that's
the basic idea of this of a subject okay
now and then you can do it but you can
actually see that you can randomize this
in various ways it doesn't give you a
strictly random graph but with these
decreases but if you ever need a graph
that has certain degree sequences is it
was an easy way to you know to generate
it and then run your program on that on
that graph it mean whatever whatever
thing you're trying to play around with
graphs and you need a graph a certain
degree sequences you can get one easy
this way and there are lots of other
modification to this and the exercises I
I show for example how to get get a
bipartite graph if you if you want to
say you know that you give the degree
sequence of each of each thing in the
first part and degree sequences of this
elusive the second part it'll decide
whether or not there is such a bipartite
graph and and there's many other things
are known about the about these things
like how connected these graphs are and
so on well that is reached by the time
when it'd be good to start distance let
me first see okay yeah
right so I i can i can give more
technical detail but I'd rather wait for
for you to ask me questions and then I
can that'll suggest without what else I
can say that that I know is it would be
of interest at least one of us are there
any question and please don assuming one
has a directed graph a directed graph
and one wants to partition it into rank
ordered sets which is to say cycles is
there a fast algorithm for partitioning
or finding the rank in a directed graph
so you have so you're asking me that
they're assessed you're asking me to
solve condo sales too low there's their
assets well in fact it is okay so so let
me let me say that one of the one of the
databases in the stanford graph-based is
his base and football scores from the
previous a nineteen ninety season and
and so I haven't hear all of all of the
scores of the of the let me see let me I
can show you an excerpt but um let me
see if I look up in the index if I look
up Stanford Cardinal I believe I'll find
and we will find the page or I can show
you that graph it's a directed graph and
then each of ok Stanford Cardinal page
31 okay yummy should search it's okay so
true so but what you asked I think is a
very you know very difficult question as
Benson but games it it's a network okay
okay d on grass if you have anything the
vertices here arcs are decorated with
additional data it's called a network so
network is a graph with plus plus
something extra so so it's also
there's for example one of these
networks in serigraph base is based on
the United States economy divided into
sectors eight-day complete flow of
dollars from 14 different sections of
the economy to each other as measured by
the government in 1985 well here's that
this one is the games one comes from
football scores and as our clip Stanford
to California value is 27 the art from
California Stanford is value 25 because
in the big game are in 1990 Stanford 127
225 now okay so it now the 1990 season
was a very interesting season from the
standpoint of your question because you
know at the end of the season they try
to say who is the number one football
team in America and so you'll have these
scores or some with some teams compete
other teams and then there are three
poles there's the UPI poll you know some
coaches will vote for this and then
there's a sociate oppressed pole and
then there's there's another poll by the
new york times i think of what and each
of those polls came up with a different
national winner year so so the question
is take the data from the stanford
graph-based and figure out what is there
what is the answer who was the the best
college football team in it in the
country so but they're just kind of
ranking uh you know I see all the Google
people here in front of me and I'm
thinking page rank you know it's that it
you know ranking outer there certainly
are certainly hot topics for long time
um and but but because paradoxical
things could happen and you can die as I
say that's generally the different
coaches came up with different rankings
of the team now one of the problems i'm
going to have involved for based on
these football scores is to figure out a
longest path algorithm and and like work
it out here
in other words you can say stanford beat
Berkeley and then Berkeley be somebody
else and then it somebody else beat
somebody else and we got and so loved by
God it in here so here it is I said
starting team Stanford other team
Harvard ok so here we go Stanford bista
beavers and gets in wrecks of 34 points
the Beavers beat the well as so 35 to 21
so now Stanford is ahead by 48 wildcats
beat the Lobos and then the Lobos beat
the miners and so on and so on Rainbow
Warriors Brigham Young finally we get
here Yale are right at seven 81 points
at Stanford over Harvard now we don't
allow intermediate teams to appear more
than twice because I mean you can't have
a loop you could make this go to
infinity okay well now this isn't this
isn't the best stuff in fact because the
but the best score of sanford over her
wood has been fouling the guys now stood
on the website but he hasn't revealed
his methods that family there's lots of
cool grout graph algorithms that deal
with ranking but i don't know if other
questions
somebody in the back of the room nope
when the room wins okay about the
algorithm that you just got before on
the other two drew I was wondering are
the solutions unique or there may be
multiple solutions to the grass oh
there's and by unique of course I mean
grasses are not is a market to each
other the solution to the degree
sequence oh yes so know that you can see
that there were there are lots of other
solutions to this that would have worked
I mean mainly I mean susa that I not the
granite are not isomorphic but and then
analyse market but there there are
interesting sequences that have only one
solution I like I go to see if I can
remember for example I think it's like
was ok so let's try this try to see if
it's going to work seven seven seven
four four three three three now so 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 to see what's what
what's going to happen here um three
three three men or four so this is going
to have to one is going to have to be
connected to all the other guys right
and and so on well two is going to have
to be 1 3 4 5 6 7 8 and three is going
to have to be 1 2 4 5 6 7 8 and so
therefore I already know that for is
this is without loss of generality so
not even isomorphism so for has been
connected to one two and three and five
has been connected to one two and three
and six has been connected to one two
and three and seven and so on so here we
are so for it better be connected to
5524 right so so there are there are
cases that that are uniquely you know
is unique thing but but that's very
unusual usually there's there's many
many cases and look by the way what I
wanted to mention that this algorithm
that I showed you the running time is
proportional to the number of edges in
the graph but if you just want to see if
the sequence is graphical but you don't
want to construct a graph doesn't say
yes or no graphic or not then there's
actually a linear time algorithm of
using the deep using just the DS or you
just run through the DS and you do some
great very clever of programming tricks
and and then you know the answer and the
the algorithm is this first of all given
the given the D given the DS like in
this case it was what a 6 6 44 4 4 4
there's also you can you can compute
with a very very beautiful short program
of you can compute the size of the
columns now this is the 11 33 99999 but
for any for any sequence DS you can find
what's called a conjugate partition the
size of the columns you can calculate
that in linear time by by a beautiful
little method i described here in
english but but but it is k then let me
run it out in the sea for you um so k
equals d 1 j equals 0 then you say while
k greater than 0 i probably use as a for
statement is better k equal j plus 1 at
k plus 1 then while k greater than D
looks like a three-judge DJ plus 1 C of
K
equal C of K minus minus both Jay and
there we go so that calculates the Seas
in menu time zips through it's a it's a
try to reconstruct it without you know
with your eyes without looking at that
she I dr. well but it does exist
independent okay so so you can find the
seat so once you got the decency and
then you can you can find that so the
burfi square of the of a partition which
is the largest square that stays inside
of the partition in this case they're
all four by fours it's not doesn't
always happen but in general you try one
by one or two by two or three with you
until you can't anymore and and those
and the rule is that you must have d1
plus DK has to be great msu c 1 plus c k
minus K greater um I think it's this way
yep yep the sum of the first k ds has to
be less than or equal to sign first AC
minus K or K less than or equal to the
size of the square so the size of the
square the S is the largest case where
we're we're adhesive k is greater than
equal ok so it's so they need to
determine s and then you make this test
of and linear time you figured out
whether the sequences graphical now he's
not easy to prove that this seek that
this condition is equivalent to that the
algorithm and in fact I found I found
flaws in in the roof that I found in the
literature about this
so I had to working i had in order to
answer one of the exercises here it took
me 15 I think it took us a couple days
longer than I expected it to yeah here
it is slow to answer on page 60 here I I
had to go through all this long
explanation here and I think it does now
constante tutte a correct truth however
nobody has checked this yet so if you
find an error in this I paid for it you
know I'm very glad to see somebody
checking it you know checking that DITA
I haven't made a mistake here maybe just
a typo but what I did if I did work hard
on this and I want to make sure it's
right because I because in several text
books they had through stuck actually
didn't have inning together and you
looked at my was hoping for you know to
make it simple isn't sure if I could
figure out how to how to do that that
condition which reminds me young as I'm
working on this this section now this
you know this was going to be festival
11 be I i spent the altogether too much
time two weeks ago on a problem that
that that's nice clean mathematical
problem it's a recurrence that that
talks about how to be able to have a
billion function you want to find a
small circuit or certain time you've got
a method that the theorem in the inlet
literature was that this thing can't
blow up and I found a bug in the proof
of that Fahrenheit
can I and I spent already two days
trying to patch the bug and i believe
the theorem but i can't find another way
so i wrote to the office of paper with
three authors and i haven't heard
anything back I don't know if I know if
they have you know they treated my
messages as spam or whatever but refuses
black hole as far as I'm concerned so it
means so it the authors should have a
chance to correct the correct the proof
that they gave first but but i but i
think it's a kind of a basic result in
some ways although liked it when I can
we book is finally done it it's like
it's got a feeling about a half a page
like this later or else if there is no
short proof on I'll have to you know
hope that somebody does publish a crack
group so that I can refer to it my
literature but right now I don't know if
that the result is correct and so if
there's anybody here in the audience who
has who wants to maybe work together I
don't want to work with just one person
but if you can find a group of two or
three people who want to be interested
in looking at this little mathematical
problem I could I could get together
with you explain to what the problem is
what I know about it and and the
computation look evidence that i have
for correctness and then and and then I
you know i can't pay anything for it
just say that is something that you
might find interesting it won't be
picking up problem that you solve it to
make PhD thesis out of it but it but it
will be worth you know was something for
your own education at least and and this
is a important enough we will result
somehow in the structure this or the
theory of of branching diagrams that
that somebody are the other side of the
question so so i'm looking for
volunteerism
it arises all the time as I'm writing it
because I don't just cool stuff out of
the literature then I try to verify
stuff that like wasn't my broken I tried
and I try to program everything before
before I presented as an algorithm so I
can sew it so I know what one feels like
okay other question way in the back so
you stocked up you can't hear hello know
if you start out with a graph with n
vertices each vertex could possibly have
a degree between 0 and n minus 1 so the
possible number of sequences sets of
vertex sequences is N squared is better
is there is there of is there like a num
is is there a formula to calculate an
algorithm to calculate how many of those
N squared sequences result in actual
graphs and how many ok yeah how common
is it for a sequence to be graphical
there was a paper I just want aspect for
paper by by professor or Liggett that
UCLA last year who discuss this question
suppose you choose the degree sequence
at random from different distributions
the uniform distribution does it
approached some probability and
unfortunately abstract the paper didn't
give the answer but but but there but if
you look up of maths I oh and the author
was Liggett lig either people
distinguish confess or just from the
counter time Liggett at UCLA and he he
wrote a paper about that question last
but i don't remember yes i know the
answer but i think that it's pretty
common that is if you if you just you
know roll dice and get get it you
probably you'll find it as ethical
what
oh I'm sorry oh that was all that that
that was in the abstract he has it said
it said yes it either goes to zero or
purchase a half or so or sometime in
between this is right the Sun the Sun
has to be eaten yes I was wondering if
there's any interesting generalizations
of this problem of the problem of for
example to hypergraphs or something like
that okay yes that one of the one of the
generalizations that ok let me effect
there have been many but I didn't go I
didn't go into too many into here so I
generalized it as I said to my part like
which is also equivalent to two directed
graphs if you look in a sense itself but
they're very well known problem over
what matrix of zeros and ones and you
want to know the Royal sums and column
signs of that matrix and and so there's
a I've been very much like algorithm
agent because a few changes we will
solve that thumb but denim a much then
Vincent's apartment where far-reaching
ones have been to say well now you want
to graph ok so I believe its unsolved
problem of guy so I'm solve problem
given the degree sequence is there a
planar graph with that degree sequence
open question but is there a is there a
self complimentary Brett with that with
that degree sequence now a self
complimentary graph is a graph that's
following this imagine that you that you
have endpoints and you and and each one
is either joined by a by a red edge or a
green edge so then the red edges define
a graph which have have this happen
after the total number of edges and the
green hedges also just because the graph
itself complementary if if if you change
the colors you still get an isomorphic
graph the graph formed by the right
ideas designs the market to the graph
so it's called a self complimentary
graph and i have several exercises about
self complimentary grass because that's
another elementary topic to discuss well
a a intricate extension of this
algorithm Asia was found by God by
clayton and and darlin wong Danny
climbin at MIT and doll muah was one of
the students and then Wong went into I
think he's now you know working in on
Wall Street of Finance and making a lot
of money instead of doing that theory
but but but he he proved this this quite
delicate theorem about to characterize
when a sequence is it is possible to
make a self complimentary grabbed Ron
and and there are other they had another
paper as well no I'm sorry that was that
wasn't dahlin one that was some kind of
clapham innings that you here Lightman
and wang proved the theorem about can
you make a graph that is like four
connected or fire or discuss the
connectedness of the graph from this
degree c so there are generalizations
like that but it but to me the most
interesting what one is just you know
the elementary problem itself and the
fact that it had a that had nice proof
but it's but it i did this afternoon
look up in math I I i gave the keywords
degree sequence and I got 180 success of
papers with that had that had that in
the title and so so you know woman
there's not many other papers on the
concept it didn't happen to use the word
degree sequence in the time so it's a it
you know there's a huge number of people
investigating questions like this
and some of the questions are more
interest in others but with that theory
of never when I was a question well
thanks for staying an extra half hour
late and have a good cool